Amir Zasch, ich bin Assistenzarzt und möchte heute mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchhören. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache jemand hilft mir.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Birte Becker.
Wie darf ich Sie ansprechen?
Frau Becker.
Frau Becker, können Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja, es fängt an mit B-I-R-T-E Birte, das ist der Vorname und der Familienname ist Becker, B-E, also A umlaut, C-K-E-R.
Entschuldigung, können Sie Ihren Vornamen noch einmal buchstabieren?
Ja, B-I-R-T-E.
B-I-R-T-E.
Birte.
Frau Becker, wie alt sind Sie?
Jetzt muss ich ganz schnell gucken. Irgendwo habe ich stehen. Ich bin 58 noch.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 15.08.67.
15?
15.08.67.
1967.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Moment, irgendwie bin ich gerade auf meinem Zettel falsch unterwegs.
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich habe es. 173.
1 Meter 73.
Wie groß sind Sie? Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, ich wiege so um die 62 Kilo.
Frau Becker, was führt Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe mit einmal so heftige Schmerzen in der linken Leiste.
Das krampft sich immer so zusammen und das wird immer schlimmer und will gar nicht aufhören.
Und was ich eben zusätzlich habe, dass ich mit einmal so schlecht Luft bekomme.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Atemnot und das macht mir halt ein bisschen Angst.
Und die Schmerzen, die sind insbesondere, wenn ich mich bewege, sind die schlimm.
In Ruhe geht das noch.
Und die strahlen auch so von der Leiste ein bisschen aus ins Bein rein und auch ein bisschen in den Rücken.
Und das ist also ja ein bisschen unheimlich.
Ja, ich verstehe, Frau Becker, machen Sie bitte keine Sorgen.
Wir werden so schnell wie möglich die Ursache Ihrer Beschwerden herausfinden.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, eigentlich hat das so vor zwei Tagen richtig angefangen.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Und ich muss vielleicht auch noch was dazu sagen.
An dem linken Bein ist mir vor vier Wochen ein Melanom entfernt worden und auch ein Lymphknoten dann in der Leiste.
Wann wurde Melanom diagnostiziert?
Ja, das ist jetzt so sechs Wochen her. Und vor vier Wochen war dann die Operation.
Okay. Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden, die gleichzeitig aufgetreten sind?
Jetzt mit den Schmerzen? Nein, das ist ja...
Aber ich denke mal schon, dass das irgendwie vielleicht zusammenhängt.
Also eigentlich war alles gut. Die Wunde ist eigentlich gut verheilt.
Und da am Bein. Aber jetzt fühle ich mich irgendwie ein bisschen schlapp.
Ja, also ich habe auch ein bisschen... Ja, also ich schlafe schlecht und ich fühle mich einfach nicht gut.
Und ja, das macht mir natürlich Sorgen.
Frau Becker, haben Sie eine Wunde im Leistenbereich?
Da war natürlich die Wunde von dem Lymphknoten, ja. Aber die war eigentlich unauffällig die ganze Zeit.
Haben Sie Geschwollen, Schwellung oder Rötung bemerkt in der Wunde?
Ich habe das jetzt nicht gesehen, nein. Aber es tut weh.
Okay. Haben Sie Überwärmung bemerkt?
Besonders warm. Also eigentlich ist mir da nichts aufgefallen. Ich habe nur eben diese Schmerzen.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie Schmerzen? Seit zwei Tagen.
Wie bitte? Seit zwei Tagen.
Seit zwei Tagen. Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, das fing langsam an und jetzt wird es immer mehr halt.
Immer mehr. Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ja, ich dachte ja, wenn ich rumlaufe, wenn ich mich bewege, dann tut es mehr weh.
Aber wenn ich Ruhe gebe, wenn ich mich hinlege, dann ist es natürlich ein bisschen besser, ja.
Okay. Frau Becker, bekommen Sie irgendwelche Therapie für Melanom?
Nein, also das ist nur operativ entfernt worden.
Keine Medikamente? Keine Chemotherapie? Keine Chemo.
Keine Chemo. Haben Sie etwas dagegen, Schmerzen eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe jetzt Ibuprofen genommen, weil ich das noch im Haus hatte, ja.
Aber so richtig doll geholfen hat es eigentlich nicht.
Kennen Sie Dosierung? Das sind 400er, deswegen habe ich auch drei Stück genommen, also über den Tag verteilt.
Ist Ihnen übel? Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie erbrochen? Nein, auch nicht. Zum Glück nicht.
Okay. Ist Ihnen schwimmig? Nein, also ich habe wie gesagt nur diese Schmerzen da in der Leiste.
Wie ist Ihr operativ?
Naja, eigentlich ist der gar nicht so schlecht, würde ich sagen.
Aber trotzdem habe ich in letzter Zeit tatsächlich ein bisschen an Gewicht verloren, obwohl ich eigentlich ganz gut esse, meine ich.
In welchem Zeitraum und wie viel Kilo verloren?
Naja, also das fing an, also noch eigentlich bevor die Diagnose gestellt wurde, ja.
Da habe ich bemerkt eigentlich, dass ich so ein bisschen Gewicht verliere und das sind jetzt acht Wochen ungefähr.
Da habe ich jetzt drei Kilo verloren.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber, Stuhlfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nee, eigentlich bin ich so, habe ich nichts in der Art, nein.
Kein Fieber? Ich fühle mich nicht heiß und ich habe auch nachts nicht geschwitzt, nein nein.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, also ich habe eigentlich nie Probleme damit, also bisher nicht, nee.
Okay. Haben Sie geschworen und gerötete warme Beine bemerkt?
Nee, also das ist mir eigentlich nicht aufgefallen, dass da irgendwo eine Schwellung ist, nee.
Okay. Frau Becker, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben, dass Sie eine Luftnot haben.
Sind Sie jetzt beschwerdenfrei oder?
Nein, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich ein bisschen schwer Luft kriege und ganz auffällig ist das natürlich in dem Moment, wo ich mich ein bisschen anstrengen.
Also wenn ich jetzt eine Treppe hochlaufe, puh, dann puhste ich, ja, als ob ich 20 Jahre älter wäre, ja.
Haben Sie blasse Haut bemerkt?
Ja, so ganz gut sehe ich jetzt zur Zeit nicht aus, aber ich denke mal, das hängt vielleicht auch noch, ja, der Winter ist gerade vorbei und also besonders blass, würde ich sagen, bin ich nicht.
Frau Becker, haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden, die glasse Zeit aufgetreten sind?
Nee, sonst ist eigentlich nichts, also wie gesagt diese Schmerzen und sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Okay. Seit wann sind Sie in den Wechseljahren?
Ja, das hat eigentlich jetzt erst so angefangen.
Wie bitte?
Das hat jetzt erst so angefangen eigentlich, also ich habe immer noch so sporadisch meine Periode, aber eben nicht mehr regelmäßig.
Seit wann?
Das hat vielleicht so vor 5 Jahren oder 3 Jahren, würde ich sagen, seit 3 Jahren ist es so ein bisschen unregelmäßig.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig den Frauen?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Alles in Ordnung?
Bisher war immer alles okay, ja.
Okay.
Ja, und ich meine diese Melanomdiagnose, das war natürlich so ein Schlag ins Kontor, da war ich schon überrascht eigentlich, dass da so was gefährliches ist, aber wir haben das zum Glück ziemlich schnell gemerkt, ja.
Gott sei Dank.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bekannt?
Bisher war ich gesund, das ist ja das, was mich so aufregt, ja.
Okay.
Entschuldigung.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, also ich hatte vor, ja wie lange ist denn das her, so 10 Jahre ungefähr, da habe ich mir mal den Arm gebrochen, kompliziert, und da, das musste wieder gerichtet werden und da haben die operiert und haben Metall eingesetzt und das ist dann nachher wieder entfernt worden, aber das ist eigentlich alles ganz problemlos gelaufen.
Okay.
Hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, also natürlich jetzt diese Melanomgeschichte da, ne?
Okay.
Frau Becker, nehmen Sie außer den genannten Medikamenten noch etwas ein?
Nee, bisher bin ich völlig immer ohne Medikamente ausgekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten gegen bestimmte Medikamente oder Substanzen?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allergisch bin.
Bisher habe ich immer alles problemlos vertragen.
Ich war immer kerngesund, ja.
Immer kerngesund.
Okay, Gott sei Dank.
Rauchen Sie oder haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, ich bin nicht Raucherin.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Ja, also ein Glas Wein trinke ich schon gerne oder auch mal im Sommer, wenn es sehr heiß ist, ein Bier, ein Kühles, aber ja, also jetzt nicht, dass ich jeden Abend ein Glas Wein trinke oder so.
Nicht jeden Abend, wie oft trinken Sie?
Vielleicht einmal in der Woche oder so und ja, je nachdem, also wenn es was zu feiern gibt, trinkt man mal ein bisschen mehr, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Nicht regelmäßig, nur ein Glas Wein oder Bier pro Woche?
Ja, ungefähr.
Ungefähr.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, wirklich nicht, nein.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Angestellte im Einwohneramt.
Ich sitze natürlich viel am Bildschirm und habe viel Publikumsverkehr.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter haben wir, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist sehr gesund, ja.
Ja, sie ist noch jung, sie ist erst 19 und sie erwartet ihr erstes Kind.
Da sind wir natürlich so ein bisschen als Eltern in Sorge, wie sie damit klarkommt.
Frau Becker, haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Alltag?
Das sage ich ja gerade mit der Tochter, dass mich das schon ein bisschen nervt,
dass die jetzt so als junge Frau, ohne dass sie ihre Ausbildung abgeschlossen hat, ein Kind bekommt.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Mit meinem Mann, meine Tochter ist ausgezogen.
Okay, sind in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bekannt?
Also mein Vater ist an Lungenkrebs gestorben und meine Mutter ...
Welchen Krebs? Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht gut verstanden.
Lungenkrebs.
Ja, der hat aber auch ordentlich geraucht.
Und meine Mutter hatte einen schweren Schlaganfall und hat sich davon auch nicht wieder erholt.
Die ist pflegebedürftig im Rollstuhl und hat also eine ziemlich starke linkseitige Lähmung.
Okay, linkseitige.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Schwester habe ich.
Ist sie gesund?
So viel ich weiß. Ja, die hatte neulich mal was gesagt, dass sie zur Darmontersuchung war
und dass die so Polypen aus dem Darm entfernt haben, aber das war wohl eine Kleinigkeit.
Okay, ja, Frau Becker, ich wäre mit meiner Befragung fertig.
Ich denke, ich habe Ihnen alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Ihre Beschwerden sind sehr typisch Wunden, Probleme, Wundeninfektionen, ich denke.
Aber das ist nur mein Verdacht. Ich werde sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen, KG schreiben und Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Wenn Sie erlauben, würde ich ein Brot abnehmen.
Ja, natürlich, wenn das notwendig ist, klar.
Wie bitte?
Wenn das notwendig ist, müssen Sie das natürlich machen, ja.
Okay.
Außerdem würde ich ein Link leisten, Ultraschall durchführen.
Das ist bestimmt vernünftiger, damit man sehen kann, was da ist, ne?
Ja, wenn die Ergebnisse vorliegen, werde ich Sie mit meinem Obarist besprechen
und danach erkläre ich Ihnen, dass weitere vorgehen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Na ja, eigentlich, ich habe natürlich jetzt Sorge, was dahinter steckt
und ob da mit dem Krebs irgendwas ist, ob da doch irgendwas gestreut hat.
Und ansonsten, ja, denke ich mal, muss ich jetzt abwarten, was Ihre Untersuchungen ergeben, ne?
Ja, zuerst körperlich untersuchen, danach Vitalparameter überprüfen und ein EKG schreiben.
Ja, das haben Sie ja gesagt, ja.
Ja, ich habe schon gesagt. Und ich taste Ihre Wunde.
Ja, ich sehe zuerst Ihre Wunde, danach Sie haben schon gesagt, manchmal Luftnot bekommen.
Deswegen höre ich Ihre Lunge ab.
Mhm.
Ja, das ist irgendwie ja komisch. Womit hängt das zusammen?
Das ist so, was mir so ein bisschen Sorge macht, ne?
Dass ich jetzt so schlecht Luft kriege, das macht mir halt so ein bisschen Sorge.
Auch weil ich an meinen Vater denke, ne?
Ja, aber Ihre Beschwerden sprechen nicht dafür.
Machen Sie bitte keine Sorgen. Wir werden alle Notwendigen untersuchen,
und unser Bestes tun.
Okay, ja.
Ja, alles klar.
Sie sind in guter Hand.
Gut, okay.
Hat jemand sätzliche Fragen?
Ja, möchte ich fragen, ich möchte.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Eine Reise? Nee, länger jetzt nicht.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auch Brustschmerzen haben, oder?
Aber ich das nicht verstanden.
Brustschmerzen nicht. Ich kriege schlecht Luft, habe ich gesagt.
Okay.
Danke.
Können Sie bitte die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben? Sind die Schmerzen zielend, stehend, drückend?
Ich würde sagen drückend.
Krampfartig.
Drückend und krampfartig, ja. Genau. Es zieht sich so zusammen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass die Schmerzen sehr heftig sind. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Ja, also, die sind nicht unerträglich, aber sie sind schon so, dass ich sie deutlich spüre.
Ich würde das nicht sagen, unerträglich, aber vielleicht so in der Mitte, vielleicht bei 5.
5? Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit bewegungslos?
Bewegungslos? Nein, so ein bisschen bewegt habe ich mich immer. Ich habe so ganz normal meine Arbeit gemacht.
Ich war ein paar Tage krankgeschrieben und dann bin ich aber wieder zur Arbeit gegangen.
Und habe ja auch meinen Haushalt versorgt und alles, ja.
Und die nächste Frage ist, ist Ihnen Herzrasen aufgefallen?
Herzrasen? Nö, habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Danke.
Gibt es noch weitere Fragen?
Frau Becker.
Ja?
Ist Atem nur plötzlich aufgetreten oder langsam aufgetreten?
Eigentlich ist die so mit den Schmerzen jetzt aufgetreten. Vorher habe ich das gar nicht so bemerkt.
Aber die ist jetzt und ist vor allen Dingen eben stärker, wenn ich mich auch nur ein bisschen anstrengen, wenn ich mich bewege.
Haben Sie auch die 4 Farbeende angewiesen?
Oh, warten Sie, ich kann Sie ganz schlecht verstehen. Nochmal bitte.
Haben Sie bemerkt, es ist eine Fieber in der Hautflage oder was?
Ich kann das nicht verstehen. Können Sie noch einmal den zweiten Teil der Frage, haben Sie bemerkt das?
Haben Sie bemerkt, eine Fieber in der Hautausschlag?
Ein Hautausschlag?
Hautausschlag.
Ein Hautausschlag habe ich, nee, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Danke.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Unserer neuen Patient heißt Birte Becker. Frau Becker ist 58 Jahre alt. Am 15.08.1968 geboren.
1,73 Meter groß und 62 Kilogramm schwer.
Die Patientin stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehender linkseitiger Leistenschmerzen vor.
Die Patientin beschreibt die Schmerzen als progredient, persistierend, drückend und krampfartig.
Die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen würden in den Rücken und ins linke Bein ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzintensität wird mit 5 und 10 auf der Schmerzskala angegeben.
Die Schmerzen würden mit Müdigkeit nach dem Lymphknotentfernung aufgetreten.
Wann war die? Und warum?
Vor vier Wochen. Lymphknotentfernung.
Vor vier Wochen erfolgte eine Lymphknoten und warum?
Wegen eines Malignis Melanums.
Vor acht Wochen wurde Malignis Melanum diagnostiziert.
Vor acht Wochen.
Die Patienten haben dagegen 400 Milligramm Tegress dreimal eingenommen.
Wogegen? Gegen die Schmerzen jetzt?
Ja, gegen die Schmerzen.
Die Patienten haben keine Chemotherapie bekommen.
Demnach war der Lymphknotenbefund in Ordnung.
Die Patienten haben eine Wunde im Leistenbereich.
Von den Lymphknoten entfernt natürlich.
Die Schmerzen würden bei Bewegung zunehmen und in Ruhe nachlassen.
Okay, kann man sich vorstellen.
Die Schmerzen würden mit Müdigkeit einhergehen.
Die Legatate angenommen ist unaufmerkbar bis auf Inapathens.
Die Patienten haben drei Kilogramm innerhalb von acht Wochen abgenommen.
In der Frauenanalyse teilte sie mit, dass sie seit drei Jahren eine regelmäßige Periode haben.
Seit drei Jahren keine regelmäßige Periode mehr oder wie?
Ja, unregelmäßig.
Sie besucht regelmäßig den Frauenarzt.
Anvor Erkrankungen nannten die Patienten seit sechs Wochen eine Malignismelanome.
Die Patienten wurden vor zwei Wochen linksseitige Lymphknotentfernung durchgeführt.
Vor zehn Jahren wurden sie aus der Synthese gegen Arnfraktur durchgeführt.
Die Patienten nehmen regelmäßig drei Mal 400 Milligramm Ibuprofen ein.
Regelmäßig? Nimmt sie doch jetzt nur, wenn sie die Schmerzen hat?
Ja, nur auf die Schmerzen.
Also nicht regelmäßig.
Die Patienten haben keine Allergen, sie sind nicht rauchig, sie trinken ein Glas Wein oder Bier pro Woche.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Die Sozialanalyse ergab, dass sie in der Einwohner-Meldung als Angestellte arbeitet.
Sie ist verheiratet, hat eine gesunde Tochter.
Sie hat viel Stress wegen ihrer Tochter.
Inwiefern?
Wie bitte?
Inwiefern hat sie Stress mit der Tochter?
Ja, ihre Tochter ist noch jung und deswegen viel Problem.
Die Patienten leben mit ihrem Mann.
In der Familienanalyse teilt sie mit, dass ihr Vater an Bronchialcarcinom verstorben ist.
Ihre Mutter hat Apoplexie und sie hat linkseitige Lähmung.
Die Patienten haben eine Schwester.
Ihre Schwester wurde wegen der Darmpolypen operiert.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich einen Verdacht auf Wundinfektion.
Was könnte es differenzialdiagnostisch sein?
Anämie.
Als Erklärung für die Dyspne.
Malignis Melanum.
Lungenkrebs.
Das könnte auch sein.
Was machen Sie jetzt für die Dyspne?
Die körperliche Untersuchung.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich habe eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Ich höre Lunge ab.
Vielleicht pathologische Atemgeräusche.
Lunge asymmetrie.
Vielleicht kann ich eine asymmetrielle Lunge sehen.
Malignis Melanum Metastase.
Ich beobachte Wunden.
Vielleicht Rötung, Schwellung.
Vielleicht auch die Schmerzen.
Röntgen Thorax.
Ich würde Röntgen Thorax heranlassen.
Einen Ultraschall für Wunden.
In dem Wundbereich und dem Schmerzbereich.
Ich würde Röntgen Thorax heranlassen.
Einen Ultraschall für Wunden.
In dem Wundbereich und dem Schmerzbereich.
Ich würde Blut abnehmen.
In Bezug auf Laborwerte würde ich ein großes Blutbild.
Entzündungsparameter.
Neben Leber- und Nierenwerte.
Elektrolyte.
Blutgasanalyse.
Der Patient hat manchmal Dyspnoe.
Deswegen würde ich Blutgasanalyse heranlassen.
Was vielleicht noch im Blut zu bestimmen?
Blut ist ok.
Ich würde das Blut abnehmen.
Das war es.
Ich habe es nicht richtig.
Also TVT-Auslussung.
FK.
Farbkodiärte.
Labortechnisch D-Dimere bestimmen.
Ok. D-Dimere.
Was würden Sie sonst noch vorschlagen?
Röntgen Thorax.
Genau.
Wir warten ab, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Dann schauen wir, ob es noch etwas gibt.
Ich habe es schon gesagt.
Dann schauen wir, was dahinter steckt.
Vor allem ist es interessant, wie die Wunde aussieht.
Ob Sie irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten entdecken können.
Ich würde auch einen Onkologen anfordern.
Sicherlich wäre das in der nächsten Runde erforderlich.
Vielen Dank.
Danke schön.
Ich danke Ihnen auch.
Kommen wir zur Manöverkritik.
Das ist ein etwas undankbarer Fall.
Er hat so wenig Informationen.
Die Patientin hat auch sehr wenig Vorerkrankungen.
Normalerweise haben wir das mit älteren Patienten zu tun.
Die haben immer eine ganze Fülle von Vorerkrankungen.
Da kann man immer aus einem reichen Repertoire schöpfen.
Wo könnte noch etwas zusammenhängen?
Hier liegt natürlich dieser Verdacht auf den Wundinfekt nahe.
Wobei dagegen spricht so ein bisschen,
was die Patientin ja nicht beschreibt.
Das hätte sie ja selber gesehen,
wenn da in der Leistenwunde irgendwas nicht in Ordnung ist.
Wenn das dick und rot wäre.
Dann wäre das eher so ein bisschen
für sie selber auch auffällig.
Da hätte sie das vielleicht auch erwähnt.
Die weniger erfreulichen und für diesen Fall zutreffend
tatsächliche Diagnose wäre dann,
dass die möglicherweise eine Filialisierung
von ihrem Maligenmelanom hat.
In die Lunge und möglicherweise auch in die Knochen.
Dass daher eben diese Rückenschmerzen kommen.
Diese ziehenden Schmerzen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
wir haben ein bisschen technische Schwierigkeiten.
Sie haben ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, mich zu verstehen.
Das hat es vielleicht für Sie ein bisschen schwer gemacht.
Aber was mir sehr krass aufgefallen ist,
dass Sie wirklich übermäßig viel äh sagen.
Ungefähr zwischen jedem zweiten Wort.
Das ist sehr signifikant.
Sie sagen also äh, ich würde äh,
immer wieder äh.
Das ist total schwer abzustellen.
Das ist so ein Pausenfüller, der liegt uns allen sehr nah.
Wir machen das alle, aber Sie machen es extrem ausgeprägt.
Versuchen Sie mit Ihren Kindern beim Essen
oder wenn Sie abends zusammensitzen, Deutsch zu sprechen.
Und die sollen Sie korrigieren, wenn Sie äh sagen.
Nicht ständig dazwischen.
Dann haben Sie sich eigentlich schön
und sehr logisch auch an Ihren
Fragenkatalog gehalten.
Hatten da eigentlich auch wenig Probleme mit der Sprache.
Und mit den Formulierungen.
Was ein bisschen häufig kam, war dieses
haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie.
Wobei diese Patientin ja tatsächlich nicht viel hergegeben hat.
Ähm, da kommt es hinzu.
Da kommt es bei mir selber auf. Wir machen das alle.
Aber eben nicht ganz so stark wie Sie.
Wir haben dann das Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Das war dann, das ist immer so, dass das sprachlich nicht ganz so
einfach ist wie der reine Fragenkatalog.
Und das hat mir aber eigentlich gut gefallen.
Wie Sie erstmal die Patientin vorgestellt haben.
Dass sie gesagt haben, also flüssig passte,
wie alt sie ist, wie schwer, wie groß.
Und weshalb sie sich vorstellt.
Denn das ist oftmals ja eine sehr holprige
Gelegenheit. Aber das haben Sie offensichtlich sehr gut in der
Formulierung gehabt. Ich weiß nicht, wie stark die
Düsseldorfer gerade auf Fachbegriffe pochen.
Sie hat ja gesagt, sie stellt sich vor wegen
Schmerzen in der linken Leiste. Ob man da jetzt
den Fachbegriff im Schmerzen im linken Inguinalbereich
weiß ich nicht. Also wäre vielleicht noch so eine
Schmerzmöglichkeit. Und Sie haben die Schmerzen sehr schön
konsequent beschrieben, haben alle Informationen zur Schmerzqualität
gut zusammengepackt.
Das hat mir gut gefallen, wie Sie das kombiniert haben. Auch das, was nachher noch in den
Nachfragen kam. Für meinen Geschmack
kam die Information, dass bei der Patientin
Zustand nach maligenem Melanomen
mit Lymphknotenentfernung besteht. Die hätte ich mir ein bisschen
früher gewünscht.
Dass das eigentlich unmittelbar kommt.
Sie kommt wegen Schmerzen in der linken Leiste.
Dazu muss man wissen, dass die Patientin
vor vier Wochen diese OP hatte.
Worauf Sie nicht so stark
eingegangen sind, ist die Dyspläne.
Das haben Sie eigentlich nur so
mit einem Nebensatz erwähnt. Und
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, haben Sie zwar
die Patientin gefragt, ob sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost, Herzprobleme,
Beinödeme hat. Aber Sie
haben das im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch nicht erwähnt.
Da kommt eigentlich der Klassiker auf die Frage nach
Fieber, Schüttelfrost, Pipapo.
Und auch die Frage nach Aufwendigkeiten bei Stuhlgang oder
Wasserlassen wurden verneint.
Sie haben das alles abgefragt, aber haben praktisch
die Ergebnisse gar nicht übermittelt.
Wahrscheinlich erschienen Sie ihnen auch gar nicht so furchtbar relevant.
Gut, dann sind wir einmal in Schlingern gekommen
mit dem Ibuprofen. Da haben Sie ja gesagt,
Sie haben ja gesagt, haben Sie dagegen was
eingenommen. Da hat sie ja gefragt, jetzt gegen die Schmerzen, ja, habe ich was
eingenommen. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass sie immer
Ibuprofen 400 111 einnimmt, sondern das hat sie
jetzt nur in diesen Tagen gemacht. Keine regelmäßige Medikation.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Krasse bei dieser Patientin, dass
die vorher nichts hatte. Die war knallgesund.
Die hatte mal diese Armfraktur, aber sonst
war die komplett gesund. Und ist natürlich
dann besonders blöd. Gut, dann sind wir
bei der
körperlichen Untersuchung. Ach so, ja,
was mir dann noch aufgefallen ist, das ist
eigentlich nur eine Windigkeit. Sie haben
gesagt, in der Frauenanamnese gab die Patientin an.
In der gynaecologischen Anamnese. Okay, danke.
Das würden die Düsseldorfer Ihnen glaube ich sonst
übel nehmen. Und dass sie so beginnend in den Wechseljahren
ist und dass sie eben seit drei Jahren,
habe ich glaube ich gesagt, eine unregelmäßige Periode hat. Gut.
Dann kommen wir zu den
anstehenden Untersuchungen. Haben Sie alles gesagt,
was man machen kann.
Da würde ich sagen, irgendwie kam
noch ein Zusatzding, dass jemand sagte,
gegebenenfalls, wenn die Wunde tatsächlich
ein bisschen schmerzhaft ist, dann sollte man
immer wieder eine Wundkultur anlegen.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist abhängig
ja von dem sichtbaren Wundbefund.
Und so wie die Patientin gestrickt ist, denke ich eben nicht,
dass es tatsächlich eine sezernierende Wunde
in der Leiste ist, weil sie das ja selber gemerkt hätte.
Also das ist schon ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich, dass sie da
eine Wunde hat, die einen Infekt hat.
Und ohne dass sie das bemerkt hat.
Gut.
Dann war hier noch, was die
Prüfer in diesem speziellen Fall nachgefragt haben.
Das war aufgehängt an der Geschichte der Mutter.
Was ist eine Hämiplegie? Was ist eine Tetraplegie?
Was ist eine Paraplegie?
Und einfach nur so,
das wissen Sie, dass die Prüfer oftmals
völlig unabhängig von dem Fall
mit einmal so Detailfragen, wie die
mit einmal so Detailfragen stellen und
ja praktisch Vokabel so ein bisschen abfragen.
Einfach als Aufhänger dann irgendwas,
so ein Nebensatz aus der Geschichte.
Und was eben hier bei diesem Fall noch ist,
dass die Prüfer Fragen gestellt haben zum malignen Melanomen.
Wohin das metastasiert
und welche Risikofaktoren es gibt.
Das waren Fragen, die jetzt hier bei dieser
Patientin in der Prüfung gestellt wurden.
Sowas kann Ihnen also blühen und passieren.
So ganz große Fehler
in der Sprache machen Sie tatsächlich nicht.
Sie sprechen eigentlich ziemlich korrekt.
Das Einzige, was wirklich massiv stört, ist
dieses Unterbrechen mit dem Äh. Versuchen Sie ein bisschen mehr
Fluss reinzukriegen in die Sätze.
Und vielleicht hilft es, wenn Sie
ein paar Sätze noch mal so sich durchformulieren.
Und einfach sagen, wenn ich das und das gefragt werde,
was gebe ich dann an,
was frage ich dann? Und einfach mal so einen Satz auch hinschreiben
und gucken, liest er sich gut?
Ist der sachlich korrekt, ist der sprachlich korrekt?
Und das dann so ein bisschen als Muster nehmen, damit Sie nicht jedes Mal
so suchen müssen. Das wäre vielleicht
noch so ein Hinweis.
Wann ist die Prüfung? Am 28. Sacht du?
Ganz viel Zeit haben Sie nicht.
Das Krasseste ist eigentlich diese
Unterbrechung mit dem Äh, die wirklich, wirklich störend ist.
Und ansonsten denke ich
alles okay. Ja? Vielen Dank.